there's one person who knows all about
being thrifty in the home kitchen it's
my mum
god I love you I love you too now you're
gonna help me cook dinner and give me
some valuable tips on how to save money
in the home kitchen right will do
excellency easy-peasy
for my ultimate thrifty dinner we're
gonna make an amazing spicy braised
oxtail now ox there was something that
we grew up with yep there's something
you do in the morning and put it in the
oven because it has to be cooked really
really slow yes I'm the dust distant
flower it's amazing how many chefs are
using ox telling their menus today some
credits very popular is very cheap as
well it's amazing how you used to make
you stretch for like five or six dinners
I don't exactly it's not that bad now I
know why we're all so skinny growing up
it wasn't that bad I'm joking come on
you know joke you see sometimes we went
to the butchers in you had maybe extra
two or three mm-hm
I used to put in the saucepan and you
had love to stock for soup was that
spicy soup that really nice Malaka Toni
and I used to make the broth Scott's
broth I remember now
or pill couple cloves of garlic no I'm
sure quick work getting that out did you
know and just peel them and I'll crush
them in the garlic crusher thank you all
right I'll sell it I'm gonna fire that
off and you can get that nice and brown
and we've all braised it in red wine and
sort of chicken stock before but I'm
gonna get this then with a Chinese
influence the Chinese absolutely love
cooking oxtail do they mm-hmm you
started cooking at home quite early on
half-half your mom died quite young very
young 26 26 so who taught you how to
cook no I think you just learn as you
get older and you learn by your mistakes
and enjoy it yes enjoy it yeah there's a
nice vegetable nut the fennel fennel
isn't it lovely
just beautiful yet use it I love them
use it in salads but no one actually
cooks it you just slice that up mum now
these are nice and round
you just slice up the chili okay just
slice it down and keep the seeds in
there because I want some heat as well
one thing you never used to do was sweat
with many spices there wasn't many
Chinese emphasis I wasn't very
adventurous with spicy pikemen no I like
ginger do you I love ginger especially
fresh coriander seeds no handful 10 mm
soy sauce and quite generous in soy
sauce at 4-5 tablespoons that helps give
it that saltiness and a nice dark rich
color on the vegetables says it raises
the meat tenderizers quicker chilies
that's nice and then a little bit of
this let's just say our rice wine
vinegar
what other tips would you give me in
order to save money on cooking what got
you through that tough time feeding all
six of us hand holding two jobs when
that was in the oven safe for about an
hour and a half you know then I would
think right I'll make a rice pudding up
an apple pie and for the scene sorry he
use the other shelf in the oven so you
weren't just watching the pennies in
terms of the produce you also turn down
the gas bill yeah Wow super now super
noon yeah some oxtail back on top of the
vegetables go chop it up is that beef
stock yeah this is a really nice chicken
stock why are you pink chicken stock in
rich because it's quite I saw a light
fragrant way of cooking on sale because
oxtail itself is quite rich yeah chicken
socks nice and light just cover it with
stock lovely colors it's a beautiful
color little taste here we go big deep
breath okay man
well that's not it I can taste the
fennel on that is it nice
that's lovely
water for man bomb man recovers from the
kick up the chili to go with my oriental
influence tops tell I'm going to knock
up a quick fresh radish salad take a
bunch of radishes and separate off the
edible leaves once washed thoroughly
place half the radishes in the bowl with
the leaves chop the remaining radishes
in half and add them to
next peel and finely slice a banana
shall ours
Adam to the radishes and seasons with
salt and pepper dress with a good
squeeze of fresh lemon juice and a
drizzle of olive oil then mix radish
salad it's that simple
Wow look at that that is beautiful
I just don't senior mouse doesn't know I
love the way you see that just slightly
down the bone there's no reason that at
all is that you care now to the table
please none
yes saluted lovely and I love that that
is beautiful
this is my ultimate thrifty dinner
sumptuous local Chinese braised oxtail
with a light and peppery radish salad
Jack Holly look nice mom what you think
it's lovely good reminder days gone by a
lot of people just lift up and sit with
her and then a good to see you super
Nana
cheers nice
[Music]